so look who's up there is going to be in
trouble
very soon pitbull was on a show recently
and one of these rap shows and um
pit bulls just slowly morphed into a
white guy well
check this out you know that's that's
the way i look at this
and even going into this i don't know if
y'all know about this but might as well
put it out there especially in your show
because y'all got folks that need this
more than anybody
we all need it there's a there's a
a rehearsal that went on that went on
before this whole is called event
201 uh-huh
uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh
october 18th 2019. this [ __ ] came out
it was ran by the john hopkins
university which is in cahoots with bill
gates melinda gates foundation
and this was a complete rehearsal what
we did right now you can look at this
update
too just to let them know they named it
they had a picture of
by the way if you guys don't believe me
pitbull has [ __ ] you money
oh no he does he doesn't need like you
no cancel his ass he don't care
from 2004 they are like a patent they
named
so therefore you have a segment where it
says segment financial what we gonna do
segment travel what we gonna do segment
what we gonna do when it comes to online
and and it said if anybody is not a part
of the narrative we're gonna take it off
off online which to me smells like
communism right cubans are cuban
it's really hard to push communism into
a couple it doesn't matter how ghetto
they are
it doesn't say it doesn't matter how
mainstream and woke all their friends
are
they the most like literally
the closest thing the latino world has
to
uh italians like they're just
hard-headed and they're like no
no communism it's but it's not we're
just we're doing a potluck
and people are bringing in like everyone
brings in one item to eat so we can all
eat at the office
nope sorry sounds like communism like
just
pick up a cake or something please no
which to me smells like communist right
you feel me and obviously that's what
our families live through and i'm sure
all of our families have
similar stories after buddy and them did
that
which the main doctor that was there his
name was
george fugao i might not remember the
verse of
[ __ ] the verse i was trying to spit
but i remember george's fingers
all right george fugao is the main
doctor for the cdc in china and a
virologist
out of wuhan big real [ __ ] now
right listen we're here now here's where
i go
after all of that happens to be about a
month later all the main ceos in the
world pun
major companies this did happen
remember right we were all saying it
before cody before code forget covered
for a second
there was a time when like why are all
these c was a lot of ceos were just
stepping down
like where are these ceos stepping down
what's what's that about
ceos in the world major companies
resign about a thousand and some chinese
so that means they pull out high
that means they take the ride high and
then they buy low
well everything went god knows what they
did that they didn't do but although i'm
talking about disney
hulu microsoft nike wells fargo
boeing you name it you look at them
i hate to say this i i know what you're
going to say and i agree with you
but i would hang out with people yeah
look i used to goof on pitbull like you
used to goof on
you threw a ninja troll at his head yeah
but like
people's kind of cool people's kind of
based
it's not even kind of based he's doing
the whole like nah man they planned this
[ __ ] dog
dog yo like do like literally bro like
they planned this [ __ ] dude
dude that's [ __ ] hilarious good for
him
you better be careful you should be
doing rap verses on tom mcdonald albums
if you keep [ __ ] around
well hang on i'm just looking and it's
just in
uh 15 young boys have come out saying
that
pitbull i told you pimples were
dangerous
get ready for it watch get ready for
i'm calling it get ready for some kind
of
after 20 years in music get ready for
some kind of all of a sudden
manufactured pit bull controversy watch
he he somebody
or he murdered so watch they're gonna
people are gonna start coming out now
with their [ __ ] freshly cashed uh
rothschild checks and they're gonna be
going
uh and then at which point pitbull up
to me and they're gonna go do you know
remember where uh
miami like miami's pretty big it's a
miami area okay just the general
vicinity of miami at the
rose bowl oh okay so
here that's famously in california oh
whatever orange ball
orange ball the rose bowl
and like that would actually that
actually works funnier for the bit
anyway
the wrong bowl you know what surprised
me about this and i will
when i saw this and it's a longer
interview you could watch a little
interview with him but
what surprised me is pretty intelligent
dude like he didn't come across like an
idiot
like i mean he's being you know he's
talking like a wigger obviously but
he's like nah man he named the doctor
he's like even [ __ ] woo hand dog and
all these [ __ ]
yo all my life all these [ __ ] ceos be
be riding out high and i'm like oh [ __ ]
oh
[ __ ] it's it's
good for him and he also was able to
name like 12 stocks off the top of his
head that you know ate [ __ ] on him
yeah you're right yeah i'm talking pepsi
i'm talking boeing i'm talking apple
google all that [ __ ] dawg
all these companies that will no longer
be having him in commercials
every dollar ever made doing duets with
kesha gone
he in four days dawg he
but like you said pitbull absolutely has
[ __ ]
you money like yeah he's got enough what
are you gonna do to the guy
i mean well you're not gonna let him
[ __ ] be another song with j.lo he
doesn't give a [ __ ]
like from 2009 to 2013
it was actually a federal law that you
could not record a pop song unless
pitbull was featured on it
i don't know why we passed that law and
i'm glad that trump got rid of that with
the executive order
but remember that there was like there
was a three year period
where it didn't matter it could be like
[ __ ] it's a quarter after a war
oh my god mr 305 you're like where why
is he on this track
on everything why is he on a country
song there really was a couple years
you're right where like
every song had pitbull in it [ __ ]
johnny cash i
hurt myself today international mr 305.
i heard that [ __ ] dog he was on
everything so he's got money
good for him man i'm i'm actually blown
away by this i
did not expect that coming out of him
because you would think that he would be
part of uh
you know a part of the the whole woke
[ __ ] and this coming out of him is like
yeah you know on my life
you know but he's not the only one
because there's a lot of rappers
that you're seeing that are saying this
now it's quite a few are like man i
don't buy this [ __ ]
well and i mean this is what happened
with um you know and i was playing like
a couple weeks ago that jamaican guy
the one that was like human no masks
yeah the mask is just a trick
they're trying to trick your mind and
it's like you guys
you people that run things and i'm not
gonna say who but people that run stuff
you've been you've been playing too many
games
and the problem is is that you've been
like let's just focus on white people
white people are bad trump bad neo-nazi
white supremacy we'll use all those same
old tropes
but the problem is is that you've been
letting the woke crowd just run wild
you've been letting the [ __ ] lefties
and black lives matter you've made it
where you
can no longer criticize a person of
color
or any of these kind of people so but
now what you're getting is
like some people of color that are
actually capable of critical thinking
that are now coming out and going yeah
i'm not getting this vaccine
and i don't buy this and what about the
great reset and they're going
what do we do like we can't because then
now what are you gonna do you're gonna
start silencing people of color
you can't do that you built this system
now we're not allowed to silence them so
we need more woke black guys we need
more woke us back like we need people
that are in this
kind of like cultural communities that
are going like and what's the deal with
all these ceos resigning